souriants ils vous mettent à l'aise sans
aucune crainte grâce aux mobiles
s'installer dans le quartier du vally
boas plaisir isabelle a pu faire un
dépistage du cancer du sein sans rendez
vous préalable et gratuitement même si
c'est remboursé par la sécurité sociale
il faut commencer les frais et tout le
monde ne peut pas les avancées des
marchés de organiser le dépistage du
cancer du sein au plus près des
habitantes avec un dispositif hors les
murs avec deux unités mobiles la
première le nouveau bus où on fait des
ateliers de prévention une rencontre
avec un médecin et dans la foulée la
patiente va dans le camion d'octobre
rose à faire ça mammographie son
échographie et est reçu par un
radiologue et repartent le soir même
avec un compte rendu au centre de
l'organisation le bailleur social des
résidences yvelines essonne qui a
mobilisé les gardiens de ces résidences
plaisir oise pour faire venir les femmes
des logements sociaux on a pu
interviewer le radiologue et déjà au
terme de ses deux premiers rendez vous
aucun aucun des aucune des deux femmes
n'avaient déjà réaliser une mammographie
voyez toute la pertinence du projet au
départ l'initiative a été faite
justement pour les quartiers dits
populaires les quartiers ou peut-être
les femmes ont plus de difficultés à
faire la démarche d'aller trouver un
médecin et de prendre des rendez-vous 24
habitante se sont inscrits et plus d'une
dizaine sont venus son rendez vous pour
participer aux ateliers de
sensibilisation
effectué le dépistage on regarde
l'examen s'il n'y a rien voilà on fait
le compte rendu ne donne à la patience
il ya quelque chose bien sûr il faut de
la suivirent dans deux autres examens
irm ponction etc et puis
il faut prévenir le médecin traitant
pour les messages et nos calanques pour
la suite c'est la première fois que ce
dispositif est déployé en ile-de-france
pour rappel le cancer du sein affecte
environ 58 mille femmes par an dans le
pays